jazz kids und herzlich willkommen aus
berlin
ihr habt gerade eben schon eine anreise
gesehen wir sind jetzt hier angekommen
am set nennt sich marlene dietrich platz
soweit ich weiß ihr seht ihr schon ein
paar klamotten
da ist der berühmte masken bus und
hinten haben wir so ein kleines catering
es ist ganz nett hier ich wusste auch
nicht was mich erwartet da was ganz cool
bin jetzt endlich angekommen
die nacht war relativ kurz aber ich
glaube so ein guter tag heute
schicken
so war der sieg eine saftbar wenn wir
gerade eben so eine kleine gift mixtur
aus orangen über integrierte gebraut wir
sehen wir gerade hier und jetzt ein
problem
nicht leute ich wurde ich wurde
umgezogen da sagen ich habe das t-shirt
die jacke und die schule fertig zeigt
unten
die jacke und schuhe gehören mir aber
die hose habe ich hier von der stylistin
bekommen es ist nachricht große sache
eigentlich dahinter erkennt man es noch
mal kein kurzes bild vorstellen aber es
geht in der aufnahme nicht scheiße aber
ihr habt ihr bestimmt chance gesehen
laufen aufgeblasen bürger gegeneinander
ein riesending kleines update
ich wurde da dem schon deftig sun
geprügelt hier am set das läuft auf ihr
volk ruhig hätte der freundliche umgang
ist durchaus gegeben hier will deshalb
begrüßt damit um papiss tisch da fühlt
man sich auf jeden fall bekommen
besitzen ihre die ganze zeit rom seit
mehreren stunden am mittag gegessen
vergessens zu bauen auf jeden fall sehr
sehr geil erbsen süßkartoffeln garnelen
kaputten sehr sehr lecker auf jeden fall
aber wenn wir nicht richtig was zu tun
ist
nochmal ich viel gedreht unter anderem
arm drücken ist hier gegen einen gegner
der young boy im armdrücken gemacht wir
haben
speed dating gemacht das haben wir mit
so pappbecher welche gemacht werden wer
zuerst irgendwie ein pappbecher team
aufbauen konnte und dann noch ein
bettengeschäft ich geschaut aber wie er
mich getraut hat werdet ihr dann im
fernsehen sehen vermutlich mal wir gehen
jetzt erst mal eine die als ist 18 uhr
wir sind seit zwölf jahren jetzt geht
für uns meint ein bisschen abdecken
leute das war jetzt gerade noch gesagt
dass wir scheinbar hotel essen können
sagt man natürlich nicht nein
man gönnt sich ja also weißt dass wegen
ihr zeugnis hotel und essen nicht etwa
vorher noch was geben
der plan war und ich will einfach mal
sagen wenn ich jetzt knipste dance event
zu machen und schon sind wir im
hotelzimmer und ist doppelt
schwitzen bad oder nicht schreibt ist in
die kommentare schreiben
die kommentare als würde ihm einen namen
und ein sprecher und dieses gesichts
steuersatz ihn so behindert
und das ist erst langsam
ich hab im ultra langsam laptop und
ultra langsames internet es tut weh
meine lieben nachdem er jetzt gerade das
thema gesehen habt es sitzen wir jetzt
gerade noch mal bei vapiano und zwar am
alexanderplatz direkt unterm alex ganz
schön klischee auf touristisch wir haben
es gerade hier aus zu essen bestellt und
ich habe gehört dass der schnaps trinkt
auch bei essen funktioniert also bereit
nur den sch'tis bibel nennt sich glaube
ich pizza kapriziöser danke burger king
für dieses tolle produkte z also leute
mein geheimtipp ihr piano berlin am
alexanderplatz kommt unbedingt dahin die
ratten sind umsonst
wir haben tatsächlich einfach 34 mit auf
unserem tisch entfernt einfach nach
hatte gerade immer gesehen
die vapiano systems sowie wieder hinten
erkennen hat die irrenanstalt
berlin-neukölln heute auslauf und sie
haben sich avengers kostüme übergeworfen
und spazieren am alex
aber leute das war's vom heutigen blog
wir beenden das erste mal ich hoffe dass
ich gut aufgenommen das zusammen ich
gehe davon aus dass gerne nach oben das
gefallen hat wir sehen das nicht so wie
der haut rein macht's gut und